What I want to do in
this video is show you
that for loops aren't the only
types of loops you would use,
although, they probably
are the most common.
You could also use
something like a while loop.
And maybe the while loop
might be more intuitive,
at least maybe in
the Python context.
You can pick.
So I'm going to write
the same program.
It's going to do the
exact same thing,
but instead using a for loop,
I'm going to use a while loop.
So I'm going to still start
with a sum equal to 0.
But I'm also going to
start with i equal to 0.
So the while loop isn't
going to automatically define
what my i values are.
And it's not going to
automatically change
my i values for me.
I'm going to have to
do that for myself.
But I want to do the
exact same behavior.
And I'm going to leave
my old code down here,
so you can compare
it a little bit.
But then I'll
delete it, because I
don't want the same
thing to be run twice.
So I'm going to
set i equal to 0.
And this, in case you're
curious, the last time,
in the for loop, i is only a
valid variable inside the loop.
Now, I'm defining it
outside of the loop.
So it's actually
a global variable.
I'm defining at
the highest level.
It can be used anywhere
inside of the program.
And so over here, let's
define a while loop.
So while-- so I'm
going to keep doing
what's inside of
the loop clause.
I'm going to do it
while i is less than 10.
Remember, we want to do it for
i equals 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9.
Everything up to, but not
including 10, all of the 0
through 9.
So while i is less than 10.
Do-- what I'm going to
put in this clause--
once i is not less than
10, or essentially,
once i is equal to 10,
don't do it anymore.
So it's going to have
the same behaviors
as this right over here.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to say sum is equal
to sum plus i.
And then I'm going to print sum.
So this is the exact
same logic that I
had when I wrote the for loop.
But I'm going to have to
add one more line here,
if I don't want this
thing to run forever.
Because in the for
loop, you'll remember,
every time we run this
clause here, as we get out
of the clause, it'll assign i
to the next element in this list
here.
Over here, we haven't
defined how i should change.
So what we have to
do is in every loop,
we have to increase
the value of i.
So we can say i is
equal to i plus 1.
And I want you to really think
about how these are equivalent,
how both of these are
equivalent things.
i's started at 0 before I
even entered into this loop.
And then sum started at
0 for either of these.
These say sum is
equal to sum plus i.
Well, that's the same print sum.
Now, over here, i will then--
once we go through this loop,
in the for loop-- i
will then be assigned
to the next element in
this list, which is 1.
Over here, there's
nothing to say to do that.
So we're just going
to say, i is now
going to be the previous i,
which is 0, and add 1 to it.
And these are
equivalent, because each
of these elements in this list,
in range of 10 that we define
it, are just 1 more
than the previous one.
So instead, we
could just say, i is
going to be 1 more
than it was before.
And so this should produce
the exact same result.
And actually, if I don't
want to get rid of this code,
if I want it there just
for future reference,
but I don't want the
interpreter, the Python
interpreter to run it, I
could comment them out.
And you comment things out
by putting a little hash
sign there.
So a hash sign there,
that literally says, hey,
interpreter, ignore
all of this stuff.
And it could be useful if
you have some code in there
that you want to just not
be interpreted for now
and maybe you want
to save it for later.
And it's also
useful, if you want
to tell someone who's
actually reading the code,
if you want to tell
a human being who
is reading the code
what this code does.
So for example, you could
write a little comment here.
What did I do?
What is that thing?
You could write a little
comment here that says,
this while loop calculates
the sum of 0 through 9.
And you'd say including 9.
So if someone were to
come back later, instead
of them having to try to
figure out what this says,
they could read your
comments, and say, OK.
This part of the code right here
calculates the sum of 0 to 9.
And I could say, and places it.
So when you put
this hash tag, it
essentially comments
out that line.
So if I want to go
to another line,
I have to put another
hashtag there.
And places it in
the variable sum.
So then people would know,
I know what it's doing.
And I know that when
all is said and done,
that the sum will be placed
in this variable called sum.
But anyway, let's run
this program, and one,
show that it ignores
these things.
If you wrote this text
without a hashtag,
the interpreter would
say, what is all this?
This isn't Python code.
But this is useful for
someone else reading it.
And it will also
ignore this down here.
So I can delete this.
Delete that line
right over there.
And then let's save it.
And then let's run it.
It gives you the exact same
results that we got before.
So let me run it.
So these are the results
that we got before.
You might remember, 0, 1, 3,
6, 10, all the way up to 45.
Now let's run this
thing, assuming
that I haven't made any bugs.
And I get the exact same thing.
I get the exact same thing.
So this while loop is
doing the exact same thing.
It's more explicitly
defining i, I guess.
And it takes you a little
bit more code to write it.
But it's the exact
same behavior.